maximilian gotzler weighs himself every
day and keeps track of his activity
levels via a wristband fitted with a
sensor
it sends the information to his
smartphone
personally i record my sleep behavior
and my movement because it's easy
but i largely do it to improve my health
to boost my feeling of well-being
if you sleep well eat well and are more
active you have an all-round sense of
well-being
the former basketball player became
aware of the fitness movement when he
was studying economics and psychology in
the u.s
he's now founded his own health startup
in berlin
his concept is to sell blood tests that
measure levels of vitamin d for 45 euros
a set
consumers prick their finger and send
the blood sample to a lab
they can also read health tips on his
fitness app he already has a hundred
clients
the steel is natural
the aim is to offer people a tool to
improve their health
it's an interface between test results
and end users
we also offer software that generates
tailored recommendations
the next health startup is not far away
its three founders refer to it as a
fitness studio for the brain
they develop computer and smartphone app
exercises that train memory and
concentration
their new venture started as a bit of
fun
when we were students we worked on it in
our free time and then during vacation
and in 2008 the first version went live
we had a lot of expertise in gaming and
we decided to add another layer by
including social components
this exercise promotes memory training
the user has to remember the correct
sequence
of unexpected this exercise is the
result of an experiment conducted 300
years ago
which revealed humans capacity for
retaining between five and nine pieces
of information
what's interesting is that people who
are cognitively challenged every day
have a greater capacity to absorb
information so capacity can be increased
if people challenge and train their
brains in the right way
in six months the company has grown from
six to eighteen employees the app
currently has a high rating on the apple
app store
that brings them an additional twenty
thousand users daily and their practical
experience is positive we had a
cooperation with we worked with an old
people's home where the residents were
given a tablet to do our exercises every
day
we adapted them especially for their age
group and made them a little slower
and we got great feedback
attracting 300 000 users also attracted
investors
uli coupe manages a venture capital fund
specialized in digital health products
he doesn't want to divulge the amount he
invested but he says the market has big
potential
in germany we spend eight percent of our
gdp on health
and that's only half of what they spend
in the u.s
the german health market is worth
several hundred billion euros which is
almost double the size of the country's
automobile industry industry
so far the market leaders have all been
us-based but with the current trend for
health startups in germany that could
change